born on May 7 1996 and raised in Seoul
South Korea faker was raised by a single
parent his father who believed that
faker was born to be a pro gamer as a
child
faker played the mova chaos but moved on
to League of Legends in December 2011
when he found the game while browsing
the web it didn't take long for him to
become sought after by several Korean
teams however having just entered high
school at the time the decision to turn
pro was a tough one in the end a faker
would drop out and join SK Telecom's t1
secondary squad a team which was
specifically built around his prodigious
talents the team immediately performed
topping their group during the og and
Olympus champions spring in 2013 a
telecom will win a 52 minute game they
get the duo and come out of the group
stages at champions winter with a
perfect form while and eventually
finishing third in the playoffs
faker quickly made a name for himself
his solo kills against ambition and a
dominant game on the block against MVP
blue gained him significant attention is
a lot faker just execute that vision of
that mid lane but it wasn't until 2013
summer finals where faker were truly
shocked the world you have just make are
nightmares you wake up in a cold sweat
you like hey curse behind right oh right
like even though I only have a bad
the meadow Baker may be in trouble your
deaf art prize the queen up for you oh
look at the quiz look at the bows faker
what was that Tanika with a huge LASIK
USS I can't put any bargain song
actually what that jewel I can't win a
half telecom of charges yes you the cake
deep Bullock space SK Telecom t1 K won
their first og in title that day earning
them a spot in the 2013 World
Championship and giving faker a chance
to prove who the medal internationally
SK Telecom t1 K carved a trail through
the event sweeping Royal Club 300 in the
grand finals to claim their first world
title potentially gonna go down 1520 min
again rest a tentacle they will be the
season 3 Wow
champion head that's a staple sense as
if it were possible his dominant
performance on the world stage even
further increased the buzz around faker
and he was looked to as the best in the
world most impressive victory and SKT is
the case Baker in the team returned home
on top of the league of legends world
and continued his merely unhindered
I jumped up there we go down and you
tied back over the wall that gets taken
out immediately by Instax maker in the
middle of everything goes out after
he'll get back he'll a double for Baker
he may not be done quite yet Nandi and
again make each Drive to get there with
propels there's the cocoon onto dandy
that's going to get another one
grip over Baker actually that's
basically on one dozen tomorrow they're
going to get the midlane go and oh the
hit and commit major plan to go to that
solar flare of it and this in the mid
lane Baker picked up the birth kill
they're going to be able to ingest it
soak up a little bit the looper behind
them alive in a big way not a nearly
goes down they take down hit very very
quickly there go dandy that double kill
for Baker ma tell me a little bit there
as well but that is it they're turning
under the Nexus and SK Telecom has not
the impossible there is a perfect even
breath k telecom t1 k @ kt going to go
who we named it
GG coming up here I feel for SK Telecom
the Nexus is going to Bowl fakers just
playing with his opponents right now but
it is impact just chewing his way
through the hairpin faker if continuous
assortment is approaches off the slide
SK Telecom t1 K
the path seemed set to another world
appearance however faker and his team
which faced their first stumbling block
with back-to-back disappointments in the
spring and summer season of 2014
[Music]
one last shot at worlds through the
regional qualifiers SKT t1 K came up
short to Nagi and white shield 301
there's a second when they're caught the
Nexus project cm is going the world what
an unlikely story for dodging shielding
the disappointing finish to the year
called for a change impact and piglet
left the team and due to the removal of
sister teams in OGN leaves SK Telecom's
two squads were merged into one bringing
in the fresh talent of Marin easyhoon
bang and wolf into the picture for the
first time faker had competition for his
starting role and he and easyhoon would
split the duties throughout the season
second down triple jumper Darin and fkd
twist on Whitney they take the three Oh
JJ we'll see you at the invitational
very good Scott and in total commuter
come bother with olive old camera
kitchen when a Google related micro unit
among four things are people looking
into ten in Peru
[Music]
tikkun come to me for watching
despite the changes to their roster SKT
went 11 and 3 and were able to punch it
to get to MSI there they swept through
the group stage however during the
finals against Edward gaming SKT decided
to start easyhoon that gets pawn a
player against whom figure had famously
struggle right now important to note
that easyhoon will be starting in game 1
as sad as I am to not see a couple game
1 I think it's the preferable choices
yes easyhoon played the first three
games and SKT went down 1-0 and whatever
they want at this point
the deputy forced to surrender there was
no way they're coming back their backs
against the wall
faker would swap back in for the fourth
game with the set key source and it's
two-on-one
pray to Gina's we see that faker is
setting up because he is being something
for SKT Calvary here Goro is trying to
take everything he goes down to bang now
4:02
SKT very low and this is going to be the
pawn cleanup ships over the wall that
stops it goes over the wall these deaf
is crying or Benet try and again a
little too far ahead
is it enough to pull the team back
though
Froese everybody and it'll all state try
to get back in the fight he will not go
down that's Grievous wounds now they're
under clear love SKT has managed to get
themselves in a good position but they
all have very low HP as they skirt
around tying in this fight
faker starts to pick up tails goes in
Sanya that's actually going to be a kill
over the bang and they won't finalize
they go out
thank your gifts a double helmet when
minion waves on the way SK t1 forcing a
deciding game 5 during the draft EDG
decided to leave Leblanc open a champion
on whom faker had never lost a
competitive game engine is he toying
with everyone fakers LeBlanc one of the
back locks it in for Game five Baker has
never lost with LeBlanc on the
competitive stage it was a decision that
would go down in history as the decision
proved to be a fate so Morgana is
actually a lane count for match up to
Leblanc
they could have to find other ways of
winning this game whether it's to
banking or to Roma
statistical categories farm wide which
was keep in the back in this game right
up against the turret is this a
finalizer from Baker here to clean up
the fight or Oh a little too tanky for
the damage they're bringing there's the
mirror image from Baker oh these guys
are dancing around fullback and Baker's
good to go in that crowd control from
hurting STDs disengaged but it's going
to be banging put himself right the
fight loros already teleported in from
the backside as well
bang falls down wolf gets one last pass
and control on to I believe that and he
goes down as well the double kill
finally coming in for font he's been
looking to get something going on the
work on it is going to go over to
clinical maker Dave takes down Baker
immediately bdg could have eyes on the
page Martin's going to be a distraction
but he's going down very fast
thank you saying and wolf now trying to
keep them from it being extinct in the
midseason Invitational here's the last
engage EDG doesn't even see the current
eyes on SKT sk telecom t1 or wife the
nexus turns are going down LPL's Edward
gaming are the 2015 midseason
Invitational champion while faker tried
his best playing well despite the
counterpick EBG would win the game and
the msi title and ii think ur his first
ever lost on the block the lost left
faker distraught
Ragna coming in onto maker faker flash
said he's in trouble here
faker turns is to get dog Nikki knows
Wow faker what do you know he's really
good
Victor there's a double kill big faker
does wait now that you're good trying to
set up openings right now there we go
[Applause]
Gilbert Baker and arrow completely
caught out do not tell the Baker's well
clearly five for a laptop after their
loss at MSI SKT bounce back goal gonna
flush it he's going to take out Marquis
Baker get the soldiers but it's not
going to die at the Ellen Baker with a
triple kill
Baker was returning to his dominant form
and now had the opportunity to win his
second World Championship on the hunt
goes in that's going to be hojin in a
real sticky situation he goes down a
fulcrum and our alternate that's going
to be
pray however has to run away from his
face SK Telecom looking to take down the
final Nexus turret it does not look good
for Kuro and his team Koo Tigers are
falling as KT will be your first ever
two-time world champion no matter his
teammates
no matter the opposition that rose
against him Baker and SKT proved to be
all but unstoppable cannot see he
non-conscious hadn't do a full rotation
21 do boom
todo posing all day Oh cookie Oh
challenges hydrated Keenan gay or
Optimus Hoggett MMA they would also ban
in the rubber at all the positions
so with two World Championships under
his belt faker set his sights on the
only international tournament he had yet
to win msi welcome ladies and gentlemen
to the League of Legends midseason
Invitational finals after the
disappointment of MSI 2015 this was
fakers chance to redeem them but they
will second but this feels like the
final fight specifying gate didn't lock
anyone up the hammer did disclose the LG
to the end he picks in hands up like
that keiki I've got four members down
they turn their attention to the Nexus
and SK Telecom continued to rule the
world as they are your next season
Invitational champion
the msi coupled with SVT's triumph at
IEM katowice earlier in the year meant
that SKT and Baker could complete the
international grand slam with a victory
that world and that right there makes it
all worth it but nothing worthwhile
comes without a fight
[Music]
welcome to the 2016 League of Legends
World Championship final live from Los
Angeles California
I'm games I think this is going to be
one for the record books Katie's the
best of all time yes the Nexus turrets
all the coaches and staple Kaos ladies
are silver straight in this case we are
going to Game five as far as the map
right now only might get bigger think of
the target when you try to turn it
around
defensive rasûlullah nature is shut down
rule against the kill teleport completed
but you as well as cube a unbreakable in
a shadow Sun's up for JJ that's not the
most important parties where to find a
just away from you he's going down gore
JJ licks them today the tower is the
focus California parent already secured
taken by SK Telecom Cuba finishes off
the defeat turns our ass to try and help
reticulum chaos will allow ambition to
use G a pot clickers f8 d they get
another kill Sam Frank all under
pressure in supplying ties with those
super minions to pour in kick around
grounds able to flash so he doesn't get
caught by Q base out and it's a war of
attrition they're just waiting for oh
I'm gonna fight you can flashes forward
chomps down to kill crowd
SK Telecom about to make that 3 kill the
curtain call is a fitting end to the
World Championship and Samsung Galaxy
are being so fun to this hour
SK Telecom overcome every challenge they
are the undisputed king of the world
despite a very close match sqt came out
victorious solidifying back-to-back
World Championship wins to go along with
completing the international grand slam
we have to highlight our world's MVP who
did some serious serious work over the
last month competition to bring SK
Telecom t1 to their third championship
and no surprise it's the man himself
faker and you doubted him to physio and
you talk xx you know this is a but
honestly he's had such an impressive
world run this guy is a he deserves it
he's the best plan to ever pick up a
mountain cable in the hood this also
marks Baker's third world championship
making him and his teammate bangies the
only two players in League of Legends
history to complete the feat SKT and
faker returned home to Korea as world
champions once again with an even bigger
target on their back but despite super
teams forming to challenge them and
significant roster changes along the way
Baker finds himself once again back at
MSI set to add another championship to
his already stocked cabinet of trophies
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]